buenas tardes angela afectarán al sector
financiero es decir a los bancos también
el sector de la energía a los
transportes a la importación y
exportación de productos rusos y también
y también habrá sanciones individuales
probablemente algo que pueda afectar a
varios oligarcas rusos aún así habrá que
ver hasta cuándo lejos van a poder
llegar los líderes europeos siguen
reunidos en bruselas han aprobado estas
sanciones pero aún hay que decidir qué
tipo de sanciones se van a aplicar que
bancos rusos les va a afectar esta
medida y por ejemplo si va a afectar al
sistema swift el sistema utilizado en el
sistema bancario el más utilizado en el
mundo según fuentes europeas lo que se
espera en todo caso es dañar seriamente
a la economía de rusia y se espera que
una vez aprobadas pueden entrar en vigor
en las próximas 24 horas sobre eso le
quería preguntar serán efectivas estas
sanciones para realmente bloquear el
avance ruso en ucrania
sin duda esta es una de las grandes
preguntas la unión europea cree que esta
es la única arma tal y como ha recordado
por ejemplo el primer ministro
luxemburgués sabía el med el que dice
que las únicas medidas que puede tomar
ahora mismo europa es este tipo es este
tipo de medidas sancionar sancionar y
sancionar y hacer el máximo daño posible
a rusia pero no militar porque la unión
europea no puede actuar pero es cierto
que si hay medidas financieras pueden
afectar seriamente a la economía rusa
como comentábamos hay que ver si ésta
afectará al sistema swift es algo que
los líderes europeos quieren que quieren
hablar aunque según fuentes europeas
justo antes de esta reunión casi lo
daban por descartado aún así la idea es
que como contábamos es dañar seriamente
la economía rusa según lo lejos que
pueden ir estas sanciones afectarán más
o menos